elle est la camair dans les eaux
troubles de la mémoire
les souvenirs c'est comme les poux
escale sa fille cachée au fond de l'eau
tu regardes la surface d'un étang
tu te dis c'est noir c'est plat il ya
caudal qui vit là dedans cité pêcheurs
tu leur balance quelque chose qu'ils
aiment et là tu commences à avoir des
trucs remuer sous la surface
tu lances ta ligne hop danse aura comme
ça par un brochet à souvenirs
et avec quoi on les a path les souvenirs
avec ça les souvenirs saemss à la
musique
alors eh bien je les nourris avec ou à
sky mais il faut aussi les sortir de
l'eau et pour ça ou un hameçon et madame
tout bête à yuna kim est de la fleur
d'oranger
moi je trouve ça fait un peu tape et à
l'hameçon il est là dedans
métaphoriquement parlant un ya quelques
effets secondaires mais l'un dans
l'autre ça vaut le voyage
ah oui j'oubliais c'est pas gratuit
50 euros la séance il faut bien le vivre